so let me say a couple of words about
norm for god's sakes i did feel a
closeness to him because he'd been on
the show so many times a couple of times
over the years you remember when norm
was on saturday night live he used to do
this a bob dole impression senator bob
dole and a couple of times i had asked
norm would you be willing to get in uh
full makeup and come on and be bob dole
because i always thought it was so great
his impression it was just funny and he
had funny lines and norm said um you
know it's a tremendous pain in the ass
to get into that bob dole makeup he said
but i love the show and i love you guys
so much i'll do it
and he would do it and and he would come
in as bob dole and it was always funny
and over the years he'd come in tell
stories and you know he's norm he's a
legend and i always thought
it was a
big sin that norm got fired from
saturday night live norm was on saturday
night for five seasons he hosted weekend
update for three years
uh he was great at it you know with that
deadpan delivery here he is delivering a
joke doing the fake news and in a
related story this week marked the 5
000th performance of the broadway
musical cats it also marked the 5 000th
time a guy turned to his wife and said
what the hell is this
norm started his career as a stand-up
comedian
he appeared on the letterman show in
1990 he told me a great story once on
the air about his dream was to appear on
the tonight show before johnny carson
retired i went to uh
los angeles california and johnny carson
already announced his uh retirement
right and johnny carson as you know used
to be able to anoint comedians i said
i'm going to be the last comedian to be
anointed by johnny carson right so jim
mccauley would come to the show you know
he's the talent scout for the tonight
show yeah he goes listen you're a jay
comic because jay leonard was doing it
monday night yeah guest host right so i
go no no i think i'm a johnny comic
that's what all my friends say you know
he's like no jay and then he's like if
you do good on jay johnny will watch at
home
you know which again again an audition
there was a lie i uh go on the tonight
show with jay leno i do my set i destroy
and then i come over and during the
commercial jay goes it was all right
okay wait a second did you ever get to
be on the carson show i never got to
meet him i i mean i never got the way
out of the show and then i got to meet
him personally in person but i could
never say to another radio guy
hey man that was okay your show
you know what i mean
like jay saying that it was just a
little bitty passive aggressive jay
being great again
yeah it was okay but then norm got the
gig on saturday night live in 1993. one
of the funny things he did was his
impression of burt reynolds here's a
little clip to remember norm in the
celebrity jeopardy he's standing there
as burt reynolds and he [ __ ] looked
like burt reynolds it was crazy this
condiment is made from mustard seeds
burke reynolds that's not my name
okay
turd ferguson
yeah what do you want
let's see chevy chase posted on
instagram i first met norm after he
played the newsman on snl he was the
best of all next to myself i know i'm
just kidding now because i'm all teared
up but norm was fired by saturday night
live because of this guy named don
olmeyer he was president of nbc's west
coast division and olmeyer was friends
with o.j simpson and norm feels he got
fired because he was making too many oj
jokes in his book o.j simpson says that
he would have taken a bullet or stood in
front of a train for nicole
man i'm going to tell you that is some
bad luck when the one guy who would have
died for you
kills you
[Applause]
great delivery david letterman tweeted
in every important way in the world of
stand-up norm was the best
an opinion shared by me and all peers
always up to something never certain
until his matter-of-fact delivery
leveled you i was always delighted by
his bizarre mind in earnest gays norm
used to do a david letterman impression
on saturday night live and you know it
was weird for norm because you know he
loves david letterman so he didn't want
letterman to take it the wrong way but
i'll give you a sample of it it's a
great cast you got you got meryl streep
diane keaton oh and you know who i
particularly enjoyed in the film was uh
was uh chong yeah he was good he was
very good
you hear that paulie enjoys charm
[Laughter]
but norm came on our show and i and i
was like what happened when you did
letterman and he told this great story i
was like i don't want to [ __ ] make
fun of it because i love david letterman
sure so i'm like i'm not i just i'll
just try to do as exact an impression as
possible but not make a comment on it
like not say
you know not make fun of him
you're right and i i so anyways then he
phones me like the next day and he's
like i'm talking to him and he's not
bringing it up you know so it goes on
for about five minutes where we're
talking about nothing so then i just
blurred out i go hey i did an impression
of you last night what are you kidding
me obviously that's why i was phoning it
right yeah so then all he said was he
goes oh yeah you know no no he goes i
don't mind it i don't mind it uh it's
all right he goes uh he goes uh
joe piscopo did an impression of me once
and i i didn't care for that because
that guy is not funny but uh great story
i love that dave called him
and didn't say anything
and then
finally norm couldn't take the pressure
and blurt it out i did an impression of
you speaking of impressions dana carvey
did an impression of uh norm for us you
also do a great nor macdonald hey yeah
yeah you get an arm you know it's a
funny thing you know water right they
bring your water here right yeah yeah i
mean everything is like you know it's
like a couch here yeah like you want to
sleep right you want to lay down right
but you know what you're not supposed to
lay down right
you know you want to lay down when they
see a couch right he was a great force i
felt on saturday night live totally and
he was fired like with no dignity and
and and the guy who fired him
norm's not funny norman is [ __ ] funny
oh he's oh man he's just he's
unbelievably funny adam sandler tweeted
every one of us loved norm some of the
hardest laughs of my life with this man
most fearless funny original guy we knew
sarah silverman tweeted norm was in a
comedy genre of his own no one like him
on the planet please do yourself a favor
and watch his stuff he was one of a kind
of all time um norm actually talked to
us a little bit about his feelings on
death whenever i'm talking to someone i
always ask them about death ah because
i'm so freaked out about death i don't
remember this
so keep in mind that he had already
secretly been fighting cancer for four
years at this point i was in edmonton in
this hotel i was doing stand-up and my
agent phone he said turn on your um
your computer you look at your wikipedia
and uh my wikipedia site i was dead
great my wicked peter said i had
overdosed the night before and i am
telling you howard
even though you of course you know it's
not true at first you go oh i don't know
but uh
it shakes you it shakes you and you want
to know why it shakes why
because you understand that one day
those will be the words right and all it
is is they just change the tenses
instead of norma donald is an american
comedian snore mcdonald was and who do
you think changed it was a decision
apparently uh you know any any folks can
do it can go on there right
now do you think about death a lot i
mean it does it is a freaky thing they
say most people can't spend more than
like a minute or two actually
contemplating their own demise yeah like
it's almost impossible for a brain to do
that well that's interesting i mean you
know i i guess that's why you do
anything is to to avoid that you know
that's why you do stuff in life that's
right to avoid that that thought because
if you know
well i mean we don't want to talk about
that
[Music]
so there's norm rest in peace norm
conan tweeted conan o'brien of course i
am absolutely devastated about norm
mcdonald norm had the most unique
comedic voice i have ever encountered
and he was so relentlessly and
uncompromisingly funny i will never
laugh that hard again i'm so sad for us
all today because
you know i i've watched this clip of
conan's show so many times it was so
great norm was a guest
and the actress
courtney thorne smith she was promoting
a movie she had done with carrot top
norman yeah yeah exactly norm just went
berserk what's the movie going to be
called
i know what it's going to be yeah what's
that
if it's got carrot top in it you know
what a good name for it'd be what's that
norm box office poison
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
oh
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
how quick is he
i mean that's what you know another
thing that uh conan said about him was
he was so unpredictable
there was an electricity just having him
sit there you just felt it because you
didn't know what he was gonna do he was
one of the best he really was there's no
question and uh the world really lost a
comedy legend yesterday